Find the probability of
rolling doubles on two
six-sided dice, numbered
from 1 to 6.
So let's just think about it.
Let's think about all of the
outcomes, all of the possible
outcomes, and then what fraction
of those outcomes
represent us getting doubles.
We want to roll doubles.
So let's make a little table
here that'll give us all of
our outcomes.
You have 6 outcomes on the first
dice, or the first die I
should say.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So let's call this
the first die.
And then the second die,
there are 6 outcomes.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
This is the second die.
So all of the different possible
outcomes are going to
be some-- you're going to get an
outcome-- so you could get
a 3 over here.
And then when you get a 3 on the
second die, you might have
gotten a 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
or 6 on the first die.
Or you might have gotten a 5 on
the first die and then you
could get a 1, 2 3, 4, 5,
or 6 on the second die.
So if I draw a grid here.
If I were to draw a grid here,
let me do my best to draw a
quick grid.
Just draw it really fast. So
let me just draw this grid
right here.
Each cell of this grid, each
box in this grid, would
represent an outcome.
All of the possible outcomes.
Let me finish drawing it.
So there you go.
And so just to get an
understanding of what I mean
by it represents an outcome.
This cell right here would
represent getting a 4 on your
first die and a 2 on
your second die.
That's the outcome
it represents.
It's one of the potential
outcomes.
Now how many total outcomes
are there?
Well you could look at the
area of this right here.
The area of this is going
to be 6 times 6.
You have 36 possible outcomes.
So 36 possible outcomes.
And it makes sense.
You can think about
the first die.
There's 6 outcomes.
And then for each of those 6
outcomes, you have 6 possible
outcomes for the second die.
So 6 times 6.
Or you can think of in
this grid, it has
exactly 36 cells in it.
Now what are the outcomes that
satisfy our conditions?
That entail us getting
doubles?
What are the outcomes there?
Well we could get a 1.
If we get a 1 on the first die,
we have to get a 1 on the
second die.
If we get a 2 on the first die,
we have to get a 2 on the
second die.
If we get a 3 on the first die,
we have to get a 3 on the
second die.
I think you see where
this is going.
4 and 4.
5 and 5.
And then 6 and 6.
So how many of these outcomes
involve us getting double?
Well, it's 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 outcomes.
So there's 6 outcomes
with doubles.
So if someone asks
you, what's the
probability of getting doubles?
The probability of getting
doubles when you rolled two
six-sided dice, numbered
from 1 to 6.
It's going to be equal to the
number of outcomes that give
us doubles-- so it's going to
be equal to 6-- over the
number of the total number
of possible outcomes.
Over 36.
And 6 over 36 is 1/6.
Now I made sure that you kind of
understood that look, these
are all the possible outcomes.
And 6 of them satisfy.
So 6 of the 36.
So there's a 1/6 probability
of rolling doubles.
But another way you could have
thought about it is, you know
what, let's just roll
the first die.
It's going to have some
number on it, right?
The first die is going to
have some number on it.
Now in order for me to have
doubles, the second die has to
have that same exact number
on it, right?
So I don't care what
the first die is.
It could be a 3, it could
be a 4, it could be a 5.
I don't know what that is.
But after I've rolled that first
die, in order to get
doubles, what the second die
roll is-- they might be almost
simultaneous-- but what the
second die rolls matters.
And so whatever number I have
on the first die, there's a
1/6 chance that the second die
is going to have that same
number on it.
So that's another way
of reasoning that
you have a 1/6 chance.
The first die does anything it
wants, but there's only a 1 in
6 chance that the second die
is going to have the same
thing as the first die.
Either way, you get to
the same 1/6 answer.